hello and welcome to this video playing
swetlana
we know Grado okay never played her even
if she you never know people tend to
play with those names okay mm-hmm just
took it so what is that that's a queen's
gambit accepted with reverse never know
cute it's probably him doesn't really
help to try to figure out a name for it
in any case I should have no problem
try to play for a 5v5 Bishop g5 e 498 d5
you know that it's the idea okay
so I'm preparing this maybe okay it's
not it's fine
c4 is possible
I cannot take Bishop age seven that
that's funny we play this pretty Bishop
d7 on Bishop a6
you know where to go Queen age five
looks like the most active move but
might be 94
you have a ticket now but should be
seven now that's a really odd game
we should be 7s 96
okay to cover c6 there are 96 now where
the threats no no no you know I can take
now
okay so it just steps into 94 him
okay
it could be a mistake and with we have
four unprotected pawns mmm okay doesn't
doesn't capture
[Music]
Jim I still have a weakness on b6 sites
that is an issue
I didn't didn't see f4 Queen d7 home
King f2 what I was thinking Quincy aide
and I didn't really see what I should do
against it I think it's two wins
Quincy eight wins
how do I have a cover the bishop I mean
Quincy eight it's extremely simple or
yeah will look something I don't I don't
know what now your engine crash or
whatever I mean it is such a fishy game
from start to finish
and now your what would now are you
and probably the engine crash yeah um I
don't know I think that that was I was
suspecting shooting from the very
beginning actually you have a
fishy-looking account yeah with with
just a couple of games played it's it's
slightly fishy looking but the whatever
what is kind of kind of weird is the now
the opening play that is somewhat
beginner Russia and then somehow have
just strong moves and unintuitive moves
but okay you can never be totally sure
of course
but we can I can do a computer analyst
request so um yeah
gotta keep it's another new account yeah
if you have some if you know a little
bit about how these she I have a little
bit of experience you sometimes spot
those those those fishy fishy fishy
accounts and games I have um yeah I'm
not 100% sure about this but it's a
little bit strange you know it starts
like with this CID takes e5 it's just no
strong player would take it just makes
no sense
you can do it without being worse and
it's then this stop fishes first move
here very narrowly but it's like okay a3
my new place like that and then they
play a three and then Knight c3 also
just this anticipating that I cannot go
if I've liked him that I cannot go if
I've because Bishop g5 again I'm not
100% sure what the whole act looked so
weird to me then here the c4 okay that
is easy to spot him but
Yeah right before ya made okay I spotted
this myself
so that it's not not a big deal but I
have somehow also queen a5 found
extremely I mean first of all Bishop e2
is not such an easy move to make when
the debt that doesn't work because of 94
but I mean no just like he just moved it
was she just missed it and here yeah
Knight you want you have to do that but
it was played and then somehow a false
it was very strong very strong
yeah 96 and now 27 and now King f2 that
is that is that is weird you know I mean
it's a strongest move according to the
engine yeah king of - but I mean if you
look at this with the human eye you just
see okay Quincy eight and the bishop is
dropping and it seems like there is this
defense
now I'm threatening here even even then
I'm not quite sure what's going on so
this is a draw and it's easily spotted
you know this and this is a draw they
are White's white saw that of course and
then didn't play Quincy aide but played
King f2 which the engine of course is
merely a queen age Queen h7 is actually
for the moment saving this and here yeah
here Quincy age should win it just winds
the winds the piece but now the engine
crashed anyway I hope it had some value
to you but it's
yeah it's just weird just weird
sometimes what's going on thanks a lot
for watching bye bye